bonjour à tous Je vous propose
aujourd'hui de suivre les meilleurs
moments des débats consacré à la
révision constitutionnelle alors vous le
savez le Sénat a adopté une version
profondément modifiée du texte issu de
l'Assemblée à l'article 2 l'article sur
la déchéance de nationalités ils ont
adopté l'amendement de Philippe le
président de la commission des lois qui
limite la déchéance aux soluls
binationaux c'était la ligne rouge fixée
par une grande majorité de sénateur
lapatridi quelques jours après ce vote
du Sénat et après plus de 4 mois de
débat François Hollande a décidé de
mettre un terme à cette révision de la
Constitution faute de compromis entre
les deux chambres ce texte devait
enteriner la mesure symbolique en effet
annoncé par le chef de l'État au
lendemain des attentats de novembre la
déchéance de nationalité pour les
terroristes voilà tout de suite donc je
vous propose de suivre ces débats en
séance j'avz la parole monsieur le
Premier ministre je vous remercie
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Gard desau
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs il y a 4 mois notre pays était
frappé par le terrorisme islamiste
frappé en sa chair frappé une nouvelle
fois moins d'un an après la tuerie de
Charlie Hebdo l'assassinat d'une
policière municipale à Montrouge et
l'attaque de l'hypercachè l'utre pays a
été frappé sur son sol il est frappé à
l'étranger et mes pensées vont vers tous
ceux lâchement abattu à
wagadougu il y a quelques semaines et
dimanche en Côte d'Ivoire ce pays ami
qui comme la Tunisie le Mali le Burkina
Faso est visé parce qu'il est un symbole
de la démocratie et de la réconciliation
en Afrique la France est pleinement
totalement au côté de nos amis Ivoiriens
notre pays a été frappé et c'est aussi
toute l'Europe qui vit sous la menace
l'intervention hier des forces de
l'ordre belge et la traque en cours à
Bruxelles lié directement aux attentat
de Paris nous le rappelle la cible des
terroristes est chaque fois la même ce
sont les valeurs démocratique la
liberté l'idéal de tolérance de respect
notre cohésion nationale et aussi le
principe de laïcité la cible c'est ce
que nous sommes et je pense notamment à
la
jeunesse il y a 4
mois jour pour
jour le chef de l'État au lendemain de
l'horreur s'adressait à Versailles à
tous les représentants de la nation
réunis en
congrès ce jour-là jour d'unité chacun
s'élev chacun applaudit pour dire son
engagement commun à assurer la sécurité
de nos compatriotes et à mené cette
guerre qui nous a été
déclarée c'est cette même unité qui a
présidé à l'adoption dès le 20 novembre
de la prorogation de l'état d'urgence un
texte adopté dans cette chambre à
l'unanimité et le 9 février à une large
majorité vous avez voté une nouvelle
prolongation jusqu'au 26 mai cette même
unité les députés de la majorité et de
l'opposition l'ont démontré lorsqu'ils
ont adopté ensemble à plus de 3/5è des
voix le projet de loi constitutionnelle
qui vous est soumis à présent oui dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée droite et
gauche malgré les débats tout le monde
les connaît en leur sein ont su dépasser
l'éclivage et se rassembler c'est ce
même chemin que nous devons prendre ici
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
l'exigence d'aujourd'hui est exactement
la même qu'il y a 4 mois rien ne serait
pire que d'avoir la mémoire courte de
céder à cette fâcheuse tendance de notre
époque celle qui veut qu'un événement
chasse l'autre n'oublions pas l'état
d'esprit de novembre ne laissons jamais
retomber nos compatriotes ne le
comprendrai pas cette exigence
d'efficacité bien sûr contre la menace
contre le terrorisme mais aussi cette
d'unité une unité sans faille car la
menace est plus forte que jamais depuis
leurs bastion de Syrie d'Irak
ou du Yémen depuis certaines zone de
repli au Maghreb ou au cel daesh l'État
islamique ou alqaïda ou akmi leur
succursal sont à l'offensive en
brigadant de jeunes combattants à
servissant des populations détournant
des richesses spoliant ces populations
pratiquant la contrebande pour se
financer leur volonté c'estétendre leur
emprise territoriale et de déstabiliser
les états c'était le but de l'attaque
menée la semaine dernière depuis la
Libye contre la ville tunisienne de
bengardan encore je l'ai évoqué de la
fusillade de Bassam en Côte d'Ivoire
l'ennemi ce sont ceux qui pent violent
tuent réduisent en esclavage ceux qui
là-bas commettent des attentats et en
planifient d'autres sur notre sol
l'ennemi ce sont aussi ces individus
embrigadés ces cellules plus ou moins
autonomes plus ou moins organisés qui
peuvent agir ici en France au cœur de
notre société ce sont ces ressortissants
français ce sont ses résidents en France
radicalisés de propagande pr à prendre
les armes pour frapper d'autres Français
pr à retourner les armes contre leur
propre pays à ce jour et le ministre de
l'Intérieur évoque régulièrement ses
chiffres plus de 2000 Français
résidant en France ont été recensés pour
leur implication dans les filières
jihadistes
sirro-irakienne depuis le début de
l'insurrection en Syrie plus d'un
d'entre eux ont rejoint cette zone de
combat plus de 600 s'y trouvent toujours
dont environ un tiers de femmes beaucoup
de mineurs aussi et
167 167 y ont trouvé la mort la justice
et les services de police agissent sans
relâche depuis le début de l'année
Bernard casenu rappelit ce chiffre en
conseil des ministres ce matin 74
personnes ont été interpellé au titre de
leur implication dans la mouvance
jihadiste 28 d'entre elles ont été
placées en détention
provisoire face au terrorisme islamiste
nous agissons nous devons agir à la
racine en frappant militairement au sel
ou au Levant nous agissons renforçant
les moyens les effectifs de nos forces
de l'ordre de nos services de
renseignement et de justice en
mobilisant nos soldats dans le cadre de
l'opération sentinelle en luttant bien
sûr contre la radicalisation et en
adoptant notre droit nous l'avons fait
ensemble au Parlement en votant des
dispositions renforçant l'efficacité de
la lutte antiterroriste et donnant enfin
un véritable statut légal aux techniques
de renseignement assortie du contrôle
nécessaire nous continuons à le faire
avec notamment le projet de loi porté
par le Garde des saau qui ce texte a lui
aussi
été adopté par une large majorité à
l'Assemblée et que vous examinerez très
prochainement et je ne doute pas là
encore que le Sénat prendra toute sa
part comme il l'a déjà fait je pense aux
propositions que vous avez formulé dans
la proposition de loi portée par
Philippe Bas et Michel Mercier adapter
notre droit c'est aussi adapter notre
Constitution le projet de loi qui vous
est soumis prévoit dans son article 1er
l'insertion dans la constitution d'un
nouvel article l'article 361 concernant
l'état d'urgence il s'agit de donner à
ce régime de crise un fondement
incontestable je rappelle que le Conseil
d'État lui-même souligné en décembre
dernier l'intérêt juridique de cette
modification constitutionnelle l'état
d'urgence est le régime de crise le plus
fréquemment utilisé sous la 5e
République vous l'aviez justement
constaté dans un rapport produit par
votre assemblée au mois de février il
serait incohérent de ne pas l'inscrire
dans notre loi fondamentale au même
titre que les régimes prévus aux
articles 16 et 36 de la Constitution ce
n'est pas qu'une question de cohérence
formelle la Constitution C règle que
nous nous fixons souverainement ce texte
qui garantit les droits des individus et
qui fondent la démocratie pouvait-elle
rester muette sur l'état d'urgence non
cette inscription qui avait d'ailleurs
été souhaité notamment il y a quelques
années par le comité présidé par Édouard
du apportera davantage de garanties les
dispositions relatives à l'état
d'urgence ne pourront plus être
modifiées par la loi ordinaire désormais
ses motifs et ses conditions de
déclaration sa durée initiale et les
modalités de sa prorogation seront fixé
dans la constitution de même que les
conditions dans lesquelles le Parlement
contrôlera sa mise en œuvre et je le dis
ici comme je l'ai dit devant l'Assemblée
nationale l'état d'urgence n'est pas
contraire à l'état de droit à nos
libertés fondamament
c'est une modalité d'application de
l'État de droit inscrire dans la
Constitution ce régime dérogatoire et
provisoire aujourd'hui prévu par la loi
c'est conforter notre démocratie la
semaine dernière votre commission des
Lois examiné le texte tel qu'il a été
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale elle
s'est prononcé en faveur de plusieurs
amendements qui seront présenté en
séance publique bien sûr par votre
rapporteur le président Philippe B et
nous en débattrons ces amendements
visent à modifier le projet existant sur
plusieurs points en rappelant tout
d'abord les prérogatives de l'autorité
judiciaire gardienne de la liberté de la
liberté individuelle même si je tiens à
souligner le contrôle strict exercé par
la justice administrative sur les
mesures mises en œuvre depuis le 14
novembre dernier en prévoyant ensuite la
possibilité pour le Parlement de
débattre à tout moment en séance
publique de l'état d'urgence le cas
échéant en examinant une proposition de
loi visant à y mettre fin en limitant à
3 mois la durée maximale de progation
contre quatre dans la version adoptée
par l'Assemblée nationale enfin en
prévoyant que les mesures prises en
application de l'état d'urgence seront
définies par une loi organique et non
par une loi ordinaire je rappelle
d'ailleurs que ces mesures en
particulier les perquisitions
administratives et les assignations à
résidence seront précisés et mieux
encadrés par un projet loi dont un avant
projet a déjà été rendu du public qui
vous sera soumis à l'issue de cette
procédure de révision constitutionnelle
nous poursuivrons ainsi la modernisation
de la loi de 1955 initiée avec le projet
de loi adopté le 20 novembre dernier une
modernisation nécessaire en particulier
au regard de la mise en œuvre actuelle
de l'état d'urgence il faut l'adapter à
la menace et au monde actuel ces
nouvelles dispositions créeront des
mesures de contrainte individualisées et
amélioreront le régime juridique des
perquisitions administratives elles
prendront bien évidemment en compte les
exigences que le Conseil constitutionnel
a fixé dans sa décision du 19 février
dernier à propos des copies de données
informatiques réalisées lors des
perquisitions administratives cette
décision par ailleurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs lève
définitivement je crois l'interrogation
sur la nécessité de la
constitutionnalisation de l'état
d'urgence nous examinerons avec
Jean-Jacques urvoise tous ces
amendements avec un esprit construc
dès lors qu'il seront conformes au
principes qui ont guidé notre travail
sur cette révision constitutionnelle
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs mardi
dernier avec le garde des saau j'ai
également exposé devant votre commission
des Lois la position du gouvernement
concernant le second article de ce
projet de loi nous abordons ces débats
dans le même esprit que lors des
discussions à l'Assemblée nationale
celui du rassemblement autour des
valeurs qui fontent notre vie en société
celui aussi bien sûr de l'unité
nationale c'est engage de cette unité
nationale je veux le rappeler aussi que
le Président de la République a proposé
la déchéance de nationalité qui était
demandée faut-il le rappeler dans les
rangs de
l'opposition le texte qui vous est
soumis est le fruit de débat très riche
passionné c'est normal D lors qu'on
aborde ces questions des débats qui en
fin de compte ont répondu à cette
question qu'est-ce pour nous dans notre
héritage dans notre tradition une nation
et la réponse ce n'est pas seulement le
droit du sang ou du sol c'est d'abord
une exigence permanente qui vaut pour
chacun d'entre nous être français
appartenir à la communauté nationale ce
n'est pas seulement partager une langue
même si c'est beaucoup ou un territoire
c'est avoir une histoire et un destin
commun c'est partag j'ai un même amour
de la patrie c'est un serment sans cesse
renouvelé au pacte républicain aux
valeurs qui le fonde liberté égalité
fraternité qui doivent bien sûr
s'incarner dans les faits et dans les
politiques publiques notre conception de
la nation ne peut pas être à géométrie
variable elle s'applique de la même
manière que l'on soit mononational ou
plurinational né français ou naturalisé
et c'est cela le sens de l'article 2 un
sens que j'assume bien sûr que le
gouvernement assume en étant pleinement
conscient de la gravité peut y avoir
aucune légèreté dans ce domaine là
attaché à toute privation de nationalité
car écarter de la communauté nationale
un individu sans autre nationalité c'est
prendre le risque de la
patridie je veux
aborder ce sujet très directement sans
détour et avec franchise le gouvernement
a d'abord voulu exclure ce risque en
limitant la déchéange de nationalité aux
seuls binationaux c'était d'ailleurs le
sens de l'intervention du président de
la République le 16 novembre comme le
propose à nouveau par amendement
certains d'entre vous mais vous le savez
il y a eu un débat des voix se sont fait
entendre sur divers band de l'Assemblée
nationale et bien au-delà dans le débat
public certains ont dit que ce débat a
duré depuis trop longtemps mais d'abord
c'est l'agenda de toute réforme
constitutionnelle et puis ce sont des
débats graves comment la France ne
pourrait pas aborder ces questions
franchement lucidement alors que les
Français au mois de janvier 2015 se sont
plus que jamais emparés de ces valeurs
de la République et qu'au lendemain les
attentats du 13 novembre ils se sont de
nouveau emparer pleinement de ce qu'est
la nation des voix se sont élevées pour
compter la distinction faite entre les
Français comméant des actes terroristes
selon qu'ils aient ou non une seconde
nationalité face à la violence de
l'attaque face à la barbarie des
attentats qui ont frappé notre pays tous
considèrent à raison que le risque
d'apatridiie ne peut en aucune manière
affranchir de cette sanction ceux qui
avec les armes ont déchiré ont rompu le
pacte républicain et c'est d'ailleurs ce
que le Sénat avait considéré comme sage
en
1998 à un moment où la menace terroriste
n'était pourtant pas ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi après ces
débats le gouvernement a proposé non
plus
d'exclure mais de limiter ce risque
d'apatridie le limiter d'abord par les
conditions posées par l'article 2 pour
prononcer la déchéance de nationalité
condamnation pénale préalable ce que
n'exige pas la convention de 1961 sur la
réduction des cas d'apatrid convention
nous souhaitons ratifier limitation au
crimes et délit constitutifs d'atteinte
à la vie de la nation crimes et délit
c'était dans le texte initial proposé
par le gouvernement ça n'était pas la
version du Conseil d'État l'Assemblée
nationale a modifié c'était une
proposition notamment de l'opposition
ajoute de la possibilité pour le juge de
prononcer la déchéance des droits
attachés à la nationalité afin de
proportionner la réponse de l'État à la
dangerosité des individus concernés
limiter le risque d'apatridie ensuite
dans l'avantprjet de loi rendu public je
l'ai indiqué à votre commission des Lois
la semaine dernière ce texte
d'application opère deux choix très
importants il définit d'abord ce qui
constitue une atteinte à la vie de la
nation ce sont ce sont les crimes et
délits constitutifs d'actes terroristes
ou attentatoir aux intérêts fondamentaux
de la nation prévu au livre 4 du Code
pénal pour les délits pour les délit je
veux le rappeler seuls les plus graves
ont été retenus ceux qui en cour une
peine de 10 ans d'emprisonnement c'est
cohérent d'ailleurs et il faut la
cohérence dans ce domainelà avec les six
déchéances prononcées depuis 2014 engagé
par mes propres soins quand j'étais
ministre de l'intérieur ou par Bernard
casneuve toutes pour des délis
d'association de malfaiteurs av
terroriste dééchéan de la nationalité
qui concernent à ce moment-là des bit
nationaux et qui n'avait pas soulevé de
contestation ou de remarques
particulières le texte d'application
modifie ensuite le régime de la
déchéance pour en faire une peine
complémentaire nous proposons ainsi que
la compétence pour prononcer une
sanction qui revient aujourd'hui à
l'autorité administrative après toujours
toujours avis conforme du Conseil d'État
revienne à l'autorité
judiciaire mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le gouvernement a bien noté
les amendements l'amendement déposé par
les présidents bas et
merciers qui propose au contraire de
figer l'état du droit actuel jusque dans
la
Constitution je respecte le
bicaméralisme je respecte profondément
le
Sénat et je connais son indépendance il
est libre faut-il le
rappeler et encore davantage dans une
révision constitutionnel qui
nécessite un vote conforme des deux
chambres et ensuite une majorité des
3/5e au congrès de proposer d'amander
d'enrichir tout texte il y a pas de
texte à prendre ou à laisser mais nous
sommes dans un
débat nous sommes au début de ce débat
ici au Sénat et je veux poser
directement cette question et vous posez
cette question quelles sont les
intentions de la majorité
sénatoriale quel message est ici envoyé
aux
Français souhaitez-vous vraiment
remettre en cause une décision qui a sur
rassembler à l'Assemblée nationale les
deux grandes familles politiques dans
quelle but ces questionsl ces questionsl
je vous les pose et je ne doute pas un
seul se instant que vous y répondrez et
je le dis ici très tranquillement très
sereinement mais c'est une lourde
responsabilité il ne sert à rien
monsieur le Président bas monsieur le
ministre Mercier mesdames et messieurs
parce que j'ai entendu la remarque il ne
sert à rien je vous le dis évitons les
sophismes d'abriter cette posture
derrière les propos du président de la
République devant le
Congrès ces
propos prop
i nous les avons entend et tous ici nous
savons aussi que le chef de l'État a
confié au Parlement c'est son rôle de
constituant et c'est l'honneur de la et
la responsabilité de la démocratie c'est
son rôle c'est sa tâche d'élaborer un
consensus sinon il peut pas y avoir de
révision ce consensus nous l'avons
construit à l'Assemblée nationale
gouvernement
majorité mais aussi une très large part
de l'opposition ce n'est pas un
compromis entre député de gauche à
l'intérieur du groupe socialiste de
l'Assemblée nationale comme j'ai pu
l'entendre ce matin sur une radio ce
texte qui vous est soumis aujourd'hui ce
n'est plus celui du gouvernement ce
n'est pas celui du groupe majoritaire de
l'Assemblée nationale ce n'est pas la
victoire d'un camp sur un autre ce texte
est le fruit d'un us
responsable méticuleux exigeant et c'est
le résultat vous le savez en tout cas
pour ce qui concerne l'Assemblée
nationale d'un pas que chacqueun a su
faire vers l'autre et vous le savez ce
consensus a été difficile parfois
douloureux dans ma propre famille
politique mais aussi dans les autres
groupe et ceux de l'opposition je me'y
suis personnellement profondément engagé
parce que je pense qu'il est
important de construire ce type de
consensus et plus de 3/5è des députés
l'ont adopté de la majorité comme de
l'opposition avec bien sûr des
différences des divisions au sein de
chaque famille mais il y a eu les
35è tous ont su se dépasser alors je
regrette profondément à ce stade bien
sûr que cette construction collective ne
puisse pas être confortée
au Sénat à l'Assemblée nationale nous
avons cherché et construit un accord au
Sénat en tout cas à ce stade vous ne
l'avez pas recherché avec personne et je
m'en étonne vous refusez ainsi à ce
stade bien sûr sur la base de ce qui a
été adopté à l'Assemblée un accord avec
cette dernière et vous le savez
parfaitement car il faut se parler aussi
directement votre proposition ne sera
jamais adoptée par une majorité de
députés je
seraiis je serai donc je serai donc très
direct l'amendement adopté par votre
commission des Lois prend le contrepied
du consensus et je ne vois pas là de
respect de la parole du président de la
République face face à cette
position je vous merci d'être les
meilleurs porte-paroles du président de
la République mais laissez-moi en
sourire un tout petit peu et je vous
vois monsieur carucci vousir être le
porte-parole du président de la
République je croyais que ici vous
portiez la parole d'un ancien président
de la République face à cette position
je veux exposer les raisons je l en
souriant qui ont justifié le choix du
gouvernement en accord avec 35e des
députés car car car car je veux
convaincre de participer à la
construction de ce
consensus la première
raison ça c'est bien parti je le
reconnais je viens de le rappeler la
première raison c'est le souci
d'efficacité cette peine de déchéance
sera prononcée immédiatement au moment
même de la condamnation par des juges
spécialisé dans la lutte antiterroriste
et notamment par la Cour d'Assise
spéciale deuxème raison le respect de
l'exigence d'individualisation de la
peine je l'ai dit la déchéance de
nationalité est une peine lourde de
conséquence qui nécessite un examen au
cas par cas c'est l'essence même de la
justice pénale d'individualiser la
sanction et donc bien sûr la déchéance
comme dans le droit actuel sera
dépourvue d'automaticité enfin 3e raison
la volonté de construire au sein d'un
régime unifié une sanction globale
prononcé en même temps que la peine
principale par les mêmes juges et non
plus tard par une autorité
administrative différente disposant de
tous les éléments de fait et de droit
ainsi lorsque le juge écartera la
déchéance de la nationalité parce qu'il
considérera cette sanction
disproportionnée il disposera encore de
la déchéance des droits attachés à la
nationalité pour compléter la peine
principale d'emprisonnement avec toute
la fermeté nécessaire certes ces
privations de droit existent déjà dans
le code pénal mais pour certaines avec
des durées limitées nous proposons ainsi
d'ajouter aux peines complémentaires une
nouvelle peine la déchéance de
nationalité et de leur conférer à toutes
un caractère définitif le Conseil
constitutionnel l'autorise compte tenu
de la gravité des infractions visées
sous réserve bien entendu d'ouvrir une
possibilité de relèvement ce que nous
proposons au terme d'un délai de 10 ans
à compter de la condamnation mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs la solution
proposée par le gouvernement est
respectueuse de l'État de droit
puisqu'elle place au centre du
dispositif l'autorité judiciaire qui
seule pourra prononcer la sanction de
déchéance au terme d'un procès équitable
respectueux des droits de la défense et
garant de l'individualisation de la
sanction cette solution est également
respectueuse de la tradition
républicaine qui a fait de la déchéance
une peine prononcée par le juge pénal
notamment en 1927 sous le gouvernement
d'union nationale de Raymond pocarré
cette solution est respectueuse enfin
des droits fondamentaux de la personne
la patride ce n'est pas comme je l'ai
entendu une mort civile une éternelle
errance il faut ici rappeler que la
France en ratifiant le 8 mars 1960 la
Convention de New York du 28 septembre
1954 a reconnu un statut protecteur
atriille c'est au nom donc d'une
certaine idée de la nation que le
gouvernement a abouti à la rédaction de
l'article 2 je ne peux donc imaginer que
la majorité sénatoriale ne soit pas au
rendez-vous et n nous trompons pas de
combat et prenons garde à ne pas
construire des oppositions inutiles
voire factices en particulier il ne faut
pas construire d'opposition inutile sur
la question du rôle de l'autorité
judiciaire je sais que sur tous les
bancs s'exprime le souci de préserver
l'état de droit et de ne pas céder sur
le terrain de la protection des libertés
et des droits fondamentaux et c'est
d'ailleurs la tradition du Sénat mais
alors comment expliquer le choix d'une
déance de d'une déchéance de nationalité
prononcer seulement contre certains
terroristes par l'autorité
administrative le ministre de
l'Intérieur et seulement pour des crimes
non plus pour les délites terroristes
graves comment expliquer que nous
préférons cela à une déchéance de
nationalité
prononcé par un juge pénal avec
possibilité de relèvement je le disais
avec toutes les garanties du droit en
toute transparence y compris pour les
délit d'association de malfaiteurs
aviser terroristes qui abritent les
organisateurs des actes terroristes
aujourd'hui devant vous je réitère la
proposition faite mardi dernier à votre
commission des Lois inscrire dans la
Constitution la compétence de l'autorité
judiciaire pour prononcer la déchéance
de nationalité et réfléchissons bien
ensemble fermer cette porte c'est
renoncer au fond peut-être au seul
compromis possible entre l'exigence
d'égalité et le refus de la patriedie
l'exigence de sécurité et de liberté
l'exigence d'efficacité et de respect
des droits le gouvernement est prêt à
cette réaffirmation du rôle de
l'autorité judiciaire nous y sommes
prêts parce que c'est ainsi que doit
répondre une nation sûre de ses valeurs
à ce déterminer jusqu'à la mort à
répandre la terreur maisesdames
messieurs les sénateurs cetteette
révision constitutionnelle c'est une des
réponses que notre nation a voulu
apporter aux attaques qui lui ont été
portées et je comprends bien sûr qu'il
puisse y avoir des débats et sur un
sujet aussi important qui touche à notre
texte suprême ils sont légitimes et ils
honorent même la démocratie mais dans un
tel moment face à la menace qui pèse sur
notre pays face au ferment de la
division que certains veulent distiller
il ne faut pas perdre l'essentiel de vue
l'unité des Français les Français attend
de nous que nous sachions rester
rassemblés que nous parvenions ensemble
à trouver un chemin commun et ce dont
les Français ne veulent plus ce sont les
postures qui ne font que diviser après
l'Assemblée nationale c'est à vous
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
d'envoyer ce message qui dit quelles
sont nos valeurs quel est notre État de
droit quelle est notre conception de la
nation le gouvernement
est disponible et toujours disponible
pour trouver le consensus nécessaire
loyalement et franchement sans jouer et
sans nous perdre à vous donc à votre
tour de rappeler ce qui fait notre
force
merci Monsieur le Premier
Ministre la parole est maintenant
président Philippe B rapporteur de la
commission des lois
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier ministre monsieur le garde des
saau madame la
Présidente chers
collègues au moment de vous présenter
les quelques réflexions que m'inspire ce
projet de révision
institutionnel je ne peux
oublier l'ambition qui lui est assignée
par le Président de la République qui en
a pris l'initiative devant nous le 16
novembre dernier il s'agit de manifester
dans notre loi
fondamentale le pacte qui unit les
Français dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme après les deux vagues
d'attentat criminels qui ont endeillé la
France en janvier et en novembre
2015 cette unité est nécessaire
elle marque la
détermination de la représentation
nationale et au-delà la détermination du
peuple français lui-même à vaincre ce
mal
absolu en proclamant l'État
d'urgence le gouvernement que vous
dirigez monsieur le Premier ministre a
pris la bonne
décision et le Sénat de son côté a pris
ses
responsabilités pour renforcer les
pouvoirs du ministre de l'Intérieur et
des préfets et en prorogeant à deux
reprises l'état
d'urgence notre emblé a d'ailleurs
constamment était au rendez-vous de la
lutte contre le
terrorisme nous avons soutenu et
renforcé la loi du 21 décembre 2012
contre le terrorisme de nouveau nous
avons soutenu et renforcé la loi du 13
novembre 2014 avant même les deux vagues
d'attentat que j'ai rappelé de la lutte
contre le terrorisme le 24 juillet
2015 la loi sur le renseignement a été
promulguée j'en ai été le le rapporteur
nous pouvons tous témoigner de la
mobilisation du Sénat pour donner de
nouveaux instruments de lutte contre le
terrorisme et de défense d'ailleurs des
intérêts fondamentaux de la nation et de
nouveau le 20 novembre dernier le 19
février de cette année quand il s'est
agit d'apporter notre soutien à l'état
d'urgence le Sénat n'a pas marchandé son
appui c'est dire que nous n'avons pas de
leçon à recevoir en ce qui concerne
l'unité de la représentation
nationale pour la
lutte contre le terrorisme le Sénat veut
l'efficacité le Sénat veille aussi à ce
que cette efficacité la plus grande
possible soit acquise dans le respect de
l'État de droit en renforçant les
garanties inscrites dans nos textes pour
chacun des textes que j'ai cité cela a
été le cas c'est la marque de fabrique
de notre assemblée que de vouloir
préserver les libertés et l'état de
droit tout en renforçant les moyens de
la de la lutte contre le
terroriste devant laité
de la situation à laquelle la France est
confrontée depuis les attentats de
janvier puis de novembre 2015 l'état
d'urgence a été déclaré le président de
la République a réuni la représentation
nationale à Versailles et il a annoncé
la révision constitutionnelle dont nous
débattons
aujourd'hui pour permettre je le cite au
pouvoir public d'agir contre le
terrorisme de guerre en conformité à
avec les principes de l'État de
droit jugeant l'article 16 et l'état de
siège inadapté à la situation il a
considéré je le cite de nouveau que
cette guerre d'un autre type face à un
adversaire nouveau appelle un régime
constitutionnel permettant de gérer
l'état de crise et il ajoutait qu'il
fallait disposer d'un outil approprié
afin que des mesures exceptionnelle
puisse être prise pour une certaine
durée sans recourir à l'état d'urgence
ni compromettre l'exercice des libertés
publiques le 16 novembre dernier le
président de la République a également
fait part à la représentation nationale
réunie à Versailles de sa
décision de proposer au Parlement
l'extension de la peine de déchéance de
nationalité pour acte de terrorisme au
Français de naissance
possédant une autre nationalité ce sont
ces termes
mêmes il a décidé postérieurement à son
discours d'intégrer cette réforme à la
révision
constitutionnelle le 23 décembre dernier
c'est donc un texte qui reflétait
fidèlement les intentions du président
de la République qui qui a été adopté
par le Conseil des ministres avant
d'être délibéré par l'Assemblée
nationale la question s'est posée pour
nous tous de savoir si cette inscription
à la fois de l'extension de la déchéance
de nationalité et par ailleurs de l'état
d'urgence dans la Constitution
correspondait à une nécessité juridique
impérieuse je vous aveis d'ailleurs
Monsieur le Premier Ministre proposer
comme vous en avez le pouvoir de saisir
le Conseil constitutionnel de la
première loi prorogeant l'état d'urgence
ce que vous n'avez pas souhaité faire à
l'époque cela nous aurait pourtant
permis d'en avoir le cœur net beaucoup
plus tôt heureusement grâce à la
procédure des questions prioritaire de
constitutionnalité le Conseil
constitutionnel s'est prononcé à trois
reprises comme il l'avait déjà fait en
1985 d'ailleurs mais de manière à
l'époque plus limitée et il a apporté
toute les garanties nécessaires sur le
fait que naturellement comme on pouvait
le penser le régime de l'État
d'urgenence et
constitutionnelle il n'y a donc pas de
nécessité juridique impérieuse
d'inscrire l'état d'urgence dans la
Constitution pourquoi le ferions-nous
alors nous le ferions
parce que justement monsieur le Premier
ministre nous sommes sensibles à cette
exigence d'inscrire dans la Constitution
qui est le pcte fondamental qui unit
tous les Français les moyens de la lutte
contre le terrorisme mais si nous le
faisons nous ne voulons le faire qu'à la
condition qu'un certain nombre de
garanties soit apporté par le pouvoir
constituant sur la mise en œuvre de
l'état d'urgence afin qu'il ne puisse
pas en être fait de mauvais usage ce
n'est pas le cas actuellement je
m'empresse de le dire mais à partir du
moment où nous mobilisons la
Constitution pour consolider le régime
de l'état d'urgence alors il faut
veiller tout particulièrement aux
garanties dont l'état d'urgence est
assorti puisque cette révision
constitution constitutionnelle n'est pas
absolument nécessaire autant faire en
sorte qu'à tout le moins elle soit
réellement utile et c'est tout le sens
du travail de la commission des
loi s'agissant de la déchéance de la
nationalité la question est plus
délicate nous sommes je le dis tout à
fait d'accord avec ce qu'a dit le
président de la République s'agissant de
la nécessité
d'étendre la possibilité de la déch de
nationalité pour des criminels
terroristes au Français de naissance
ayant une autre nationalité car
actuellement seul les Français qui ont
acquis cette nationalité pendant leur
vie sont exposés à la déchéance de
nationalité il s'agit donc d'unifier le
régime de la déchéance de nationalité le
président de la République a sou
apporter une limite à cette extension de
la déchéance en considérant qu'il ne
fallait pas créer
d'apatride l'Assemblée nationale et
c'est son
droit n'a pas souhaité suivre la
proposition du gouvernement celle du
président de la République sur ce point
et a adopté d'autres
dispositions je dois
dire qu'en matière de déchéance de
nationalité pas plus que pour l'état
d'urgence il ne me semble
pas que l'inscription dans la
Constitution de cette déchéance de
nationalité s'imposait avec la force de
l'évidence mais mais je suis
sensible à l'examen qu'a fait de cette
question le Conseil d'État et je
considère qu'on peut par
conséquent estimer qu'il vaut mieux
prendre endre cette garantie à titre de
précaution plutôt que de se trouver dans
la situation où il n'y aurait pas
d'extension de la déchéance de
nationalité du tout et c'est la raison
pour laquelle la commission des lois a
accepté de rentrer dans le raésonnement
que nous propose le président de la
République et à sa suite le gouvernement
en adoptant une disposition permettant
l'extension de la déchéance de
nationalité mais nous n'avons pas
souhaité monsieur le Premier ministre à
la Commission des
permettre la création d'apatride il y a
une première raison à cela c'est que ce
serait parfaitement inefficace du point
de vue de la lutte contre le terrorisme
parce que on imagine souvent que grâce à
la déchéance de nationalité on va
pouvoir expulser un étranger qui s'est
rendu coupable de CRIM grave oui on doit
pouvoir le faire s'il a une autre
nationalité mais s'il est apatride et
bien s'il est apatride il faut le garder
sur le territoire national car la France
a des engagements internationaux qui
sont très clairs et qui empêchent
d'expulser des apatrides elle doit
appliquer une protection qui est celui
qui est celle liée au régime de la
patriie j'ajoute monsieur le Premier
ministre que le débat a été de mon point
de vue rendu plus opâque par les
déclarations du gouvernement car vous ne
pouvez pas à la fois renoncer à ce qui
était au cœur de l'initiative du
Président de la République à savoir
empêcher la patridie dans la disposition
constitutionnelle et nous dire que cette
garantie vous allez la poser dans un
texte subordonné que ce soit à
l'occasion de l'adoption d'une loi ou à
l'occasion de l'adoption d'une loi
autorisant la ratification d'un traité
car s'il s'agit d'une garantie
fondamentale ça n'est pas dans le texte
subordonné qu'elle doit figurer c'est
dans le texte constitutionnel et après
après tout c'est vous qui nous invitez à
réviser la Constitution et bien soyons
cohérents si nous révisons la
Constitution ce n'est pas pour mettre
les garanties essentielles dans des
textes de loi ordinaires ou dans des
lois autorisant la ratification d'une
convention j'ajoute que le texte qui a
été adopté par l'Assemblée nationale sur
cette seule question
comporte une latitude pour le
législateur de demain qui ne lasse pas
d'inquiéter les défenseurs des libertés
publiques car au lieu de circonscrire
strictement la possibilité qu'aurait le
législateur du futur d'autoriser des
déchéances de nationalité il esttend
comme on n'aurait pas pu imaginer de
l'étendre si il n'y avait pas cette
révision constitutionnelle la révision
constitutionnelle ça doit nous protéger
pour l'avenir protéger les générations
futures et ça n'est donc pas par des
textes qui étendent à l'excès la
possibilité pour le législateur de
porter atteinte à des principes
fondamentaux que nous devons réviser la
Constitution je refuse que cette
révision constitutionnelle soit la porte
ouverte demain à des
excès nous avons à la Commission des
lois adopter un certain nombre
d'amendements dans la fidélité à ce qui
fait la vocation même de notre assemblée
en ce qui concerne la défense des
libertés s'agissant de l'état d'urgence
nous avons voulu dire que les mesures
prises dans le cadre de l'état d'urgence
comme l'exige déjà le Conseil
constitutionnel doivent être nécessaires
adapté et proportionné nous avons voulu
définir avec précision les pouirs
pouvoir du Parlement il ne suffit pas de
dire qu'il se réunit de plein droit
encore faut-il préciser ce qu'il a le
droit de faire quand il se réunit de
plein droit et notamment qu'il a le
droit de mettre fin à tout moment à
l'état d'urgence et la commission des
lois dans son unanimité tient beaucoup à
cet aspect de la question et enfin
puisque le débat a lieu puisque nous
avons de nombreuses occasions dans tous
les textes que nous avons débattu sur la
lutte contre le terrorisme de rentrer
dans ce débat j'ai souhaité et la
commission des lois m'a suivi qu'il soit
fait référence à l'article 66 de la
Constitution dans la mise en œuvre des
pouvoirs de l'état d'urgence ça n'est
pas parce que nous faisons un régime de
pouvoir exceptionnel qu'il faut déroger
aussi à l'article 66 de la
Constitution s'agissant de la déchéance
nous respectons le régime actuel de la
échéance c'est un décret en Conseil
d'État qui vous a fait reproche monsieur
le Premier ministre d'avoir signé des
décrets accordant la déchéance sur avis
conforme du Conseil d'État qui vous a
dit que le Conseil d'État n'avait pas
convenablement rempli son rôle pour
vérifier que les conditions était réunie
et pourquoi changer ce système
l'acquisition de la nationalité
française c'est une décision de
souveraineté le retrait ou la déchéance
de la nationalité française c'est aussi
une décision de souveraineté
il est exact que nous n'avons pas
inscrit les délit parmi les causes
possibles de la déchéance de nationalité
mais je vais vous donneré l'explication
Monsieur le Premier Ministre elle est
très simple dans la proposition de loi
que nous avons débattu nous avons décidé
que les délis les plus graves en matière
de terrorisme devait être désormais
qualifié de crime et être assorti de
peine de prison beaucoup plus lourde
mais en revanche nous ne voulons pas que
pour des délits qui seraient punissables
de peine d'un an de prison le
législateur du futur s'arroge le droit
de déchoir de sa nationalité un
délinquant il nous paraît tout à fait
essentiel que la déchéance de
nationalité soit réservée à la sanction
d'infraction extrêmement grave et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons été
extrêmement intransigents sur ce point
enfin je dois vous dire que il me paraît
indispensable que la
condamnation qui peut donner lieu
ensuite à déchéance de nationalité soit
une condamnation définitive tant qu'on n
pas épuisé les voies de recours il ne
doit pas être question de prononcer la
déchéance de
nationalité monsieur le Premier
ministre le Sénat se prononcera en toute
indépendance vous l'avez vous-même
souligné mais nous n'avons pas besoin de
votre autorisation pour
cela en
fonction de ses propres convictions
comme semble-t-il l'Assemblée nationale
l'a fait elle aussi c'est la condition
d'un dialogue équilibré entre nos deux
assemblées et respectueux de chacune
d'elles et ça n'est pas en renonçant à
nos convictions
que nous ferons aboutir cette révision
constitutionnelle mais au contraire en
posant clairement les principes qui
inspire notre vote et nos
amendements je sais
aussi que le compromis qui est intervenu
à l'Assemblée nationale est avant tout
un compromis entre le gouvernement et le
groupe majoritaire à l'Assemblée
nationale car j'ai bien
entendu beaucoup de députés à
l'Assemblée nationale
exprimer leur attente très forte à
l'égard du Sénat cela non accepter de se
prononcer sur la révision
constitutionnelle que parce que nous
avions pris l'engagement de réécrire le
texte ils ont vis-à-vis de nous une très
forte attente nous ne souhaitons pas
naturellement la
décevoir et Monsieur le Premier Ministre
vous avez utilisé un
terme excusez-moi je vous
demande de le retirer il n'y a pas eu de
consensus à l'Assemblée nationale j'ai
bien entendu les divisions qui ont
opposer le gouvernement au groupes
majoritaires puis les divisions des
membres de ce groupe majoritaire il y a
eu un compromis consensus et compromis
ce n'est pas la même chose et si même si
même il y avait eu et si même il y avait
eu consensus à l'Assemblée nationale je
vous rappelle les règles de la révision
constitutionnelle ces règles sont sages
il faut que tous les pouvoirs publics
constitutionnels en soi d'accord le
président de la République qui prend
l'initiative le gouvernement qui le lui
propose et qui défend le texte
l'Assemblée nationale qui l'adopte le
Sénat qui à son tour ou avant
l'Assemblée nationale selon qu'il est
saisi en premier ou en
adopte le texte et il y a donc là quatre
institutions qui doivent se mettre
d'accord elles sont à égalité de droit
ensuite le président de la République
doit proposer le texte s'il est adopté
en terme d'identique à référendum c'est
la règle de droit commun il peut y
échapper s'il ne souhaite pas faire
souscrire le pays directement à la
révision constitutionnelle en convoquant
le Congrès c'est une formule subsidiaire
et dérogatoire il lui appartient de Ch
choisir naturellement en fonction de la
préférence qu'il manifestera voilà
monsieur le Premier ministre mes chers
collègues ça n'est pas un pas que
chaqueun comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure doit faire vis-à-vis de l'autre
c'est un pas que chaque assemblée doit
faire vis-à-vis de l'autre et que chacun
des quatre pouvoirs publics
constitutionnels doit faire vis-à-vis de
l'autre nous assumerons en ce qui nous
concerne pleinement nos responsabilités
comme nous l'avons toujours fait pour
pour lutter contre le terrorisme avec
plus d'efficacité et dans le respect de
l'État
droit
merci merci monsieur le président de la
commission des lois il est grand temps
de mettre un terme à ce sinistre débat
sur dans la révision
constitutionnelle qui n'a cessé depuis 4
mois d'abîmer la France et l'unité des
Français 4 mois perdus à tenté de
justifier un projet de révision
constitutionnel dont l'efficacité face
aux menaces terroriste n'a cessé d'être
contesté par les voies les plus
illustres et les plus diverses et dont
la dangerosité pour nos libertés
fondamentales a été amplement démontré
moi je ne fais pas une loi nous
proposons pas une loi une révision
constitutionnelle et les moyens pour tel
ou tel en fonction de sa religion je le
fais pour protéger tous les Français
parce que ceux qui ont été attaqués ceux
qui ont été tués le 13 novembre à Paris
ils étaient de toutes les confessions de
toutes les religions de toutes les
générations de toutes les couleur alors
Monsieur Pierre Laurent je suis aussi
républicain que vous aussi attaché à la
République aussi attaché à la démocratie
aussi attaché aux droits fondamentaux de
mon pays aussi attaché que vous et
autant que vous de gauche donc je ne
n'accepterai aucune leçon dans ce
domaine aucune leçon parce que c'est
trop facile c'est trop facile Monsieur
Pierre Laurent de monter à la tribune du
Sénat de délivrer de leçons sur la
sécurité des Français et de ne voter
aucune loi pour protéger nos
compatriotes madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier Ministre messieurs
les ministres Mesdames et Messieurs
chers collègues vous l'avez tous dit
avant moi il y a 4 mois jour pour jour
le 16 novembre nous étions réunis en
Congs à Versailles et le débat que nous
abordons aujourd'hui est fondamental
fondamental dans la lignée de ce qui
s'est passé le 13 novembre et
s'est passé le 16 novembre au Congrès je
pense qu'il faut comme l'a fait tout à
l'heure le Premier ministre et d'autres
intervenants se replonger à la source de
ce qui nous amène à cette révision
constitutionnelle dans les heures qui
viennent nous devrons dans tout ce débat
nous souvenir de l'esprit de Versailles
oui il existe un esprit de Versailles
celui de la France debout celui de celui
de tous les parlementaires luttant
unanime contre le terrorisme alors
permettez-moi de rappeler quelques faits
le contexte dans lequel s'est tenu ce
congrès
oui vous le saviez nous le savons tous
le 13 novembre 14 15 le pays était
traumatisé ces attentats ont était
terrible une nuit d'effroid on ne savait
pas combien il y aurait de de morts
l'attente du du bilan était incertain et
surtout nos valeurs avaient été mises à
mal les terroristes avaient attaqué
notre cadre de vie nous savions pas si
cela allait reprendre continuer
s'arrêter et combien il y aurait de de
victimes les témoignages que nous avons
eu directement pour les membres du
gouvernement ù nous par les médias nous
a montré combien l'horreur avait frappé
notre sol c'était un weekend de grande
inquiétude ce drame était d'une violence
inimaginable d'ailleurs ce drame nous a
touché nous a tous glacé et durant ces
jours l'exécutif a été omniprésent le
chef de l'État s'est rendu sur place et
a montré sa grande capacité à affronter
les événements le Premier ministre les
membres du gouvernement ont géré cette
situation avec
maestria rappelons-nous l'incroyable
gravité de nos
conversations lorsque le président du
Sénat nous appelit pour nous tenir au
courant les présidents de groupe de ce
qui se de ce qui se passait de voir
lesffroid du peuple les mesures qui ont
été prises la convocation des
parlementaires à l'Élysée le dimanche
l'annulation du congrès annuel des des
maires de France oui le pays a été
touché en son cœur et nous sommes passés
prês me semble-t-il d'une rupture de
notre pacte républicain nous avions été
quelquesuns à le pointer il y a 4 mois
au congrès de de Versailles il est
important de ne pas laisser germer dans
notre société chez certains de nos
concitoyens le moindre discours de haine
oui de haine contre telle ou telle
catégorie de Français en fonction de sa
religion de ses origines parce qu'il
seraient différent qu'ils aient des
convictions différentes notre pays était
au bord de la rupture il fallait donc
une réaction à la hauteur de ce
traumatisme et l'exécutif a eu cette
réaction à Versailles moins de 3 jours
après les attaques le chef de l'État a
apporté aux Français des réponses
qui à mon sens ont pu faire oublier
cette rupture le président de la
République a joué un rôle d'unificateur
de la nation et le congrès au congrès de
versaill nous avons tous applaudi son
discours debout nous l'avons tous fait
parce que c une réponse aux actes de
guerre un programme de renforcement de
notre protection une célébration
patriotique utile et nécessaire ce
discours a été salué debout par tous les
parlementaires non pas parce que que
telle ou telle phrase y était ou n'y
était pas ce n'était pas l'analyse du
texte que nous applaudissions mais
c'était bien parce que le discours
entier du chef de l'État répondait à ce
qui se posait comme un risque pour la
nation et je crois que le Congrès de
Versailles à ce moment-là a été utile à
notre pays utile pour faire face utile
pour garder une unité au moment où le
terrorisme nous ébranlé et oui suite à
ce congrès de
cette révision constitutionnelle est
utile il est important de montrer à nos
concitoyens l'unité des parlementaires
au côté de l'unité des Français versaill
était une étape nécessaire et cette
traduction en acte était
incontournable tout d'abord nous avons
prolongé l'état d'urgence et puis à
nouveau prolongé ici même et encore
récemment avec une très large majorité
dans dans le même temps l'Assemblée
nationale a fait de même et notamment a
voté récemment le projet de loi pour
renforcer la lutte contre le terrorisme
et son
financement nous le voyons nous sommes
capable en tant que représentation
nationale de faire preuve d'unité quand
l'essentiel est en jeu et cette révision
constitutionnelle s'inscrit dans cette
trajectoire elle est porteuse d'une
solidité pour l'état d'urgence sa
constitutionnalisation c'est inscrire
une garantie quant à l'utilisation de ce
régime d'exception les guerres ont
changé de forme les réponses de notre
République doivent changer aussi et
c'est le sens de cet article 1 j'en
viens maintenant pour conclure à
l'article 2 celui qui a fait débat qui
fait le plus débat à droite comme à
gauche le groupe socialiste et
républicain n'est d'ailleurs pas unanime
sur ce sur ce texte certains collègues
se posent des cas de conscience c'est
leur libre choix et leur liberté un
amendement soutenu par une trentaine de
nos collègues sera mis en débat pour
supprimer cet article 2 mais dans tous
les groupes politiques à l'Assemblée
comme au Sénat les positions n'ont pas
été unanimes parce que sur des sujets
comme ceci il faut essayer de se
rassembler et je le dis ici je suis
favorable à ce que des terroristes
condamnés so soi sanctionné par une
déchiance de nationalité nous sommes
nombreux à soutenir la volonté du
Président de la République nous pouvons
acquérir une nationalité mais nous
pouvons aussi la perdre lorsqu'on se
retourne contre la nation cette réforme
constitutionnelle pour qu'elle soit
adoptée il faut qu'elle soit non
partisane 35e de socialiste 35è de
républicains 35e de l'Assemblée
nationale 35e du Sénat et nous pourrions
arriver à cela aujourd'hui mais
l'amendement de du président de la
commission des lois tel qu'il est
présenté aujourd'hui nous semble poser
un problème quant à ce rassemblement et
quant à l'optation des
3/5è nous vous savez très bien que
réétablir
explicitement la la mention de
binationaux de plurinationaux dans
l'article 2 revient un texte qui
diviserait et empêcherait cette réforme
l'Assemblée nationale ne l'accepterait
pas et nous nous ne l'accepterons pas
alors évidemment j'ai entendu ce que
disait le président bas tout à l'heure
le Sénat n'a pas à faire un copier-collé
de l'Assemblée nationale comme disait
monsieur Mercier le Sénat n'a pas à
s'aligner devant l'Assemblée nationale
mais évidemment l'inverse non plus
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas à
s'aligner devant le Sénat et n'a pas à
faire un copiercoller de ce qui se
passerait au Sénat et c'est la raison
pour laquelle c'est la raison pour
laquelle pour arriver si nous sommes
tous honnêtes intellectuellement ce que
je pense et si nous voulons arriver à
une réforme constitutionnelle alors
effectivement il faudra que l'article 2
du Sénat tel qu'il est rédigé par le
président bas s'il doit être voté soit
changé sans cela vous le savez très bien
on va pas se raconter d'histoire vous le
savez très bien si c'est le cas il n'y
aura pas de majorité des 3/5e il n'y
aura pas il n'y aura pas d'accord
transpartisan donc il n'y aura pas de
congrès et on peut appeler un chat un
chat alors il y a ceux peut-être qui
veulent pour diverses raisons qu'il n'y
ait pas de congrès d'autres qui
souhaitent l'avir mais en tout cas la
réalité la réalité vous le savez très
bien elle est celle-là alors c'est la
raison pour laquelle moi je
voudrais je voudrais lancer un appel
solennel au nom de mon groupe au au
président du Sénat j'ai entendu les
toutes les déclarations du présid
président du du Sénat je pense monsieur
le Président si vous le jugez utile que
vous devriez assez vite convoquer les
présidents de groupes et les groupes de
ceux qui veulent qui sont favorables à
ce qu'il y ait une réforme
constitutionnelle à ceux qui sont
favorables que nous avention pour
préparer une réunion avec l'Assemblée
nationale parce que vous le savez très
bien que ce genre de débat doit se
passer nous sommes des constituants doit
se passer dans l'hémicycle mais vous
savez très bien que pour y arriver ce
n'est pas faisant un texte ici un texte
ailleurs et en revenant que ça marchera
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent que
le Parlement réunis les parlementaires
réunis en constituant ne peuvent pas
sauter à la corde au gré des amendements
ou des textes qui sont mis ici ou là à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat et c'est la
raison pour laquelle monsieur le
Président je pense que si vous acceptiez
cette proposition nous pourrions
peut-être avancer pour trouver non pas
un consensus comme le disait tout à
l'heure monsieur Mercier en tout cas un
compromis parce que et je conclus en 12
secondes madame la madame la présidence
dans les moments que nous avons vécu
dans ce pays fracturé et divisé avec
beaucoup de nos concitoyens qui doutent
l'attitude que doivent avoir les
parlementaires réunis pour la réforme
constitutionnelle les parlementaires
constituants c'est d'essayer d'aller au
bout d'aller au bout de nos convictions
d'aller au bout d'une histoire d'aller
au bout tout simplement de valeurs qui
nous sont chèes cell de la République en
nous disant que quand la France est
attaquée quand la patrie est en danger
comme nos grands anciens nous sommes
capables de nous rassembler au nom des
valeurs cardinales de notre République
merci merci monsieur le Président
Guillaume madame ester Benbassa pour le
groupe écologiste a maintenant la
parole
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Premier
ministre monsieur le
gardessau monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues le 13 novembre
dernier la France a été frappée par les
attentats les plus meurtriers perpétrés
depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale 130
personnes y ont perdu la vie l'ampleur
et la violence de ces événements nous
ont rappelé de la manière la plus
douloureuse qui soit la vulnérabilité de
nos démocratie face à la menace
terroriste réunie en congrès à
Versailles le 16 novembre nous
parlementaires étions convaincus de
l'urgence qu'il y avait d'agir
efficacement contre cette menace pour
assurer la sécurité de nos
concitoyens le président de la
République y a prononcé devant nous et à
l'adresse du pays un discours grave et
fort mais dans l'esprit et le
vocabulaire ont pu surprendre certains
je le cite nous sommes dans une guerre
contre le terrorisme djihadiste qui
menace le monde entier et pas seulement
la
France de quelle guerre parlait donc le
président les criminels qui s'en
prenaient à nous étai donc des soldats
les soldats de quel état devions-nous
donc reconnaître à daesh la dignité d'un
état dans ce même discours le président
François Hollande préconisait une
réforme de la Constitution afin de
permettre au pouvoir public d'agir
conformément à l'état de droit contre le
terrorisme de guerre de cette mise en
scène est né le projet de loi
constitutionnelle de protection de la
nation qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui une première question vient
à l'esprit est-ce bien le rôle d'une
constitution d'organiser la lutte contre
le
terrorisme puis est-il légitime d'y
insérer de nouveaux articles qui à cet
égard même et de laaveœu de tout
observateur sensé ne seront d'aucune
porté
pratique Nils muisniex commissaire au
droit de l'Homme du Conseil de l'Europe
écrit je le cite les terroristes se
nourrissent des peurs ils veulent nous
faire croire que nous devons choisir
entre liberté et sécurité or une
démocratie n'a pas à faire ce choix un
État démocratique doit s'opposer à la
barbarie du terrorisme en évitant
d'affaiblir l'État de droit et le
respect des droits de l'homme ne pas
réussir à trouver cet équilibre serait
une victoire pour les terroristes fin de
citation c'est exactement ce que nous
voulons au lieu de chercher à comprendre
non pour excuser mais pour agir
efficacement et palier nos propres
faiblesses nous continuons d'empiler les
lois liberticides comme nous l'avons
fait après les attaques de janvier 2015
sans pour autant hélas empêcher la
tragédie du 13
novembre simplement parce que ces lois
ne sont qu'une parade politique qui ne
rassure que l'exécutif et certains
politiciens soucieux de ne pas rater
leur réélection si par malheur un autre
attentat se
produisait mais beaucoup moins nos
concitoyens que l'état de guerre
proclamé plonge dans la paralysie et la
peur d'un même mouvement l'exécutive
tente de divertir ainsi le peuple au
sens pascalien d'autres problèmes aussi
urgents comme le
chômage l'article 1er de notre texte qui
a pour objectif de constitutionnaliser
l'état d'urgence tiendrait d'une part à
renforcer les garanties des droits
fondamentaux et libertés publique et
d'autre part à adapter ce régime
d'exception à la nouvelle menace
terroriste ces arguments répétés comme
un mantra lors des débats à l'Assemblée
nationale sont peu
convaincants de quelle garantie
s'agit-il en fait en gravant dans le
marbre de la Constitution la possibilité
pour le législateur de fixer les mesures
de police administrative que les
autorités civiles pourront mettre en
œuvre en violation des libertés et
droits fondamentaux c'est au contraire
l'arbitraire du pouvoir législatif qui
est ainsi
constitutionnalisé quant à l'idée que
constitutionnaliser l'état d'urgence
permettrait d'adap ce régime à la menace
terroriste actuelle elle paraît pour le
moins contradictoire l'état d'urgence
est et doit rester une mesure temporaire
prise pour répondre à un péril imminent
or il me semble que le terrorisme auquel
nous faisons face est pour reprendre
l'analyse du politologue Bernard Manin
une menace épisodique mais par nature
permanente j'ajouterai que le terrorisme
peut être comparé à l'IDRE de l'Herne de
la mythologie antique ce monstre aux
multiples têtes qui repoussaient à
mesure qu'on les coupait s'imaginez
pouvoir dissuader d'agir par
l'accumulation de dispositions
législatives des personnes qui n'ont ni
foi ni loi relèvent de la gajure et
trahit une paresse de l'esprit que nos
gouvernants mett d'énergie à modifi en
vain notre Constitution témoigne aussi
du peu de respect qu'ils ont pour la
Constitution elle-même mais aussi du peu
de respect qu'ils ont du législateur en
lui faisant perdre un temps précieux
qu'il pourrait employer à d'autres
objectifs cruciaux comme sortir le pays
du marasme économique si ce projet avait
émané de la droite la gauche l'aurait
critiqué avec
véhémence il me paraît en outre d'autant
plus vite de sens que nous aurons à
débattre bientôt d'un 1e projet de loi
visant à renforcer la lutte contre le
crime organisé le terrorisme et leur
financement et à améliorer l'efficacité
et les garanties de la procédure pénale
associé à l'article 2 l'article sur
l'état d'urgence contribue à plomber un
peu plus un climat social déjà délé TER
loin de cette unité nationale entre
guillemets qu'il est peut-être sage de
souhaiter facile de proclamer mais
beaucoup plus difficile à
réaliser qui peut croire que l'article 2
qui constitutionnalise la la menace
d'une déchéance de nationalité va nous
protéger des terroristes qui n'ont que
faire de leur nationalité et de leur
passeport doitis-je rappeler le le
clivage qu'a créé cet article aussi bien
à droite qu'à gauche et pourquoi a-t-il
créé ce clivage parce qu'il ne s'agit
plus ici d'opinion partisane l'enjeu est
d'une autre nature il s'agit d'une
atteinte aux valeurs cardinales de notre
République il me semble que monsieur le
Premier ministre n'est pas gêné outre
mesure par l'absence de portée pratique
de ces dispositions pourvu que le
symbolle y
soit c'est un peu ce que pensaient hier
les partisans de la peine de Mor une
fois qu'on était parvenu à leur
démontrer son inutilité il y avait
encore le symbole et de quel symbole
parlons-nous ici le d'un symbole négatif
source de division il semble que pour
certains de nos gouvernants l'histoire
singulière de notre pays compte pour
rien l'acrobatie rhtorique à laquelle on
s'est livré en supprimant la mention de
bination non juste pour obtenir le vote
des députés n'y changera rien personne
n'a été dupe cet article ne concerne que
les binationaux et pas les uninationaux
sauf à fabriquer des apatrides ce que
les traités signés par la France
l'interdisent quelle catégorie de
citoyens de seconde zone Créton ici
comment parler encore ici d'unité
nationale au nom de cette unité je vous
le rappelle celle-ci souhaitait vrai
le général de Gaul à la sortie de la
guerre dans une France meurtrie préféra
pour les collaborateurs active
l'indignité nationale à la déchéance là
il y avait un symbole fort nous
pourrionsnous pas opter pour la même
démarche pourquoi ne pas consacrer tous
nos efforts à nous mobiliser autour de
la prévention et de la réduction des
menaces que le terrorisme fait peser sur
notre corp social en y mettant à la fois
plus d'intelligence et plus de
pragmatisme pourquoi modifier notre
Constitution dans laquelle doivent se
reconnaître des millions de Français en
y insérant un article céléra inspiré de
l'extrême droite qui ne s'appliquera au
mieux qu'à une poignée d'individus ne
méritant certainement certainement pas
d'être même mentionné dans la Charte
fondatrice de notre République
avons-nous pensé à l'usage que pourrait
en faire cette extrême droite si un jour
elle arrivait au
pouvoir comme le résume très bien l'avis
de la Commission nationale consultative
des droits de l'homme en
constitutionnalisant la déchéance de
nationalité je cite ce sont les
fondements mêmes du pacte républicain
qui se voit remis en cause alors que non
sans paradoxe cette remise en cause est
l'un des objectifs poursuivis par les
auteurs d'actes de
terrorisme exécutif législateur acteur
de la société civile il nous incombe
aujourd'hui de ne pas céder à la
facilité ni un doute douteux confort
intellectuel et ce en mémoire des victim
l'inflation législative n'est rien
d'autre des lois oui mais en nombre
raisonnable et raisonnable
elle-même associée à un grand nombre
d'autres outils de compréhension et
d'action du terrorisme pour ces motifs
le groupe écologiste s'opposera à la
constitutionnalisation des deux mesures
dont nous débattons je vous remercie mes
chers collègues les deux articles
principaux de ce projet de loi peuvent
paraître sans point commun pourtant il
ils partagent le même ADN ils ont en
commun cette peur que j'évoquais la peur
du quotidien pour l'une de la menace
annoncée martelée la peur de l'autre
pour la seconde cette révision
constitutionnelle est aujourd'hui
débattu alors que depuis
1986 plus de 20 lois censé protéger
notre pays contre le terrorisme ont été
voté quelle
efficacité quelle utilité à terme
l'inefficacité l'inutilité sont deux
reproches qui sont souvent sur les
lèvres de nombreux détracteurs de votre
projet Monsieur le Premier Ministre
détracteurs présents sur tous les bancs
y compris ceux de votre propre parti
peut-être avant de vous précipiter dans
un contexte peu propice à la réflexion
aurait-il fallu écouter consulter
comprendre et sans doute penser dans le
silence de ses passions comme jean-jaces
Rousseau le recommandait le premier
point de votre projet de loi c'est la
constitutionnalisation de l'état
d'urgence votre justification celle
d'une sécurisation d'un état d'exception
a vite été balayé par la plupart des
observateurs et professeurs professeurs
de droit constitutionnel devant la
commission de l'Assemblée nationale vous
avez même vendu la mèche si je peux me
permettre conférer une base
constitutionnelle à l'état d'urgence
c'est consolider les mesures de police
administrativ définies par la loi de
1955 le professeur Olivier be auditionné
par la commission des lois la affirmer
sans ambage je cite la
constitutionnalisation n'est pas
innocente loin d'encadrer les conditions
de l'état d'urgence elle permet d'aller
plus loin dans la répression et aggrave
les atteintes aux libertés oui nous
sommes en guerre tout simplement parce
que on a déclaré la guerre depuis
l'étranger à la France certains
l'oublient trop
vite certains même ont pu considérer que
le terme de guerre était un terme trop
fort trop militaire je voudrais leur
rappeler cette phrase vous ne vous
intéressez pas à la guerre mais la
guerre
elle s'intéresse à vous c'est une phrase
de Trotski en d'autres
termes en d'autres
termes cité cité par jeanv
ledrillant en d'autres termes vous
pouvez vous pouvez vouloir pour vous
pouvez vouloir ignorer vos ennemis
jusqu'au moment où eux ont décidé de ne
pas vous ignorer et nous y sommes
évidemment oui nous sommes en guerre la
menace est là elle est planétaire elle
est sur notre sol elle est aigu elle n'a
jamais été aussi aigu vous nous l'avez
les uns et les autres suffisamment
rappelé elle est permanente elle est
durable
elle est durable et il faut nous armer
évidemment sur tous les plans y compris
sur le plan juridique nous ne devons
avoir qu'une seule obsession la
protection des Français la protection de
la France évidemment face à cette
barbarie face cher Michel Mercier qui
citait tout à l'heure à nent ce queon
aurait pu appeler cette fiction
monstrueusement
cohérente c'est ce que nous avons voulu
régulièrement faire Monsieur le Premier
Ministre ici en soutenant tous les
textes de la lutte contre le terrorisme
tous pas moins d'une
demi-douaine tous
jamais notre majorité ne vous a manqué
dès lors que il il s'agissait de
l'intérêt supérieur du pays jamais et
c'est avec le même esprit de
responsabilité que nous avons accueilli
il y a 4 mois très exactement jour pour
jour les proposition du Président de la
République dans sa déclaration il y
avait la proposition qui nous a surpris
à l'époque de révision constitutionnelle
avec ces deux
volets l'état d'urgence et puis la
déchéance sur le premier volet
évidemment quelques doutes mais pas
d'hésitation sur le fond pas
d'hésitation pour le fond parce que nous
avons pour ce qui nous concerne pour ce
qui concerne mon groupe toujours
considéré qu'il n'y a pas d'opposition
entre d'une part les libertés publiqu et
d'autre part l'ordre public c'est-à-dire
et je l'ai déjà dit ici que la liberté
et la sécurité ne sont pas des sœurs
ennemies elles sont des sœurs siamoises
donc pas d'opposition sur le fond un
doute une hésitation bien sûr et
Philippe B l' magistralementand rappelé
tout à l'heure est-ce que ça nécessitait
une réforme de la Constitution je me
rends à ces arguments je me rends aussi
aux arguments de la vie du Conseil
d'État en revanche sur le deuxième volet
les choses ont été très différentes et
le débat s'est enflammé il s'est
enflammé très vite pour ce qui concerne
la déchéance de nationalité je voudrais
y revenir un instant pour expliquer la
position du groupe le plus complètement
possible et si finalement et si
finalement mes chers collègues il est
juste que la qualité de Français puisse
acquérir par le droit du sol il est
aussi parfaitement légitime que la
qualité de Français puisse se perdre par
le prix du sang le sang des Français
versés le sang des Français
massacrés alors bien sûr je sais il
reste une difficulté et je l'aborderai
monsieur le Premier ministre comme vous
l'avez fait au moins dans les termes et
dans la
proclamation sans détour et avec
franchise la
patridie je voudrais non pas vous
convaincre mais expliquer élever un
certain nombre de
prévention la première l'égalité vous
aviez à la Assemblée nationale moins ici
mais c'est à l'assemblée que vous aviez
exprimé assez clairement cette idée que
ce qui vous heurtait c'était la question
de l'égalité et vous aviez dit très
exactement pour que il y ait
responsabilité égale devant chacun il
doit y avoir égalité aussi devant la
sanction ce sont vos termes très exacts
mais il n'y a pas d'égalité aujourd'hui
devant la sanction il n'y a pas
d'égalité dans le Code civil puisque
pour les binationaux c'est le sujet de
l'acquisition et pas de la naissance et
demain et demain entre les binationaux
et les mononationaux et bien la
déchéance friverit les seconds les
mononationaux de toute patrie alors que
pour les binationaux évidemment il
resterait toujours une patrie donc le
concept de légalité il nopère pas ce
n'est pas moi qui le dit vous souriez
mais vous allez moins sourire quand vous
relirez la vie du Conseil d'État c'est
la vie du conseil que je viens
d'exprimer en d'autres termes Monsieur
le Premier Ministre avec conviction mais
pour vous convaincre aussi que ce
concept d'égalité et que cette passion
d'égalité peut nous égarer nous avons
voté les excellents amendements de la
commission des lois et du président bas
mais personnellement je voterai contre
l'article 1er parce que les postures bon
soyons pas dupes et puis c'est normal
nous sommes une assemblée politique et
il faut que nous rtions une assemblée
politique c'est toujours une bonne chose
mais quand même
j'ai sous les yeux ça me rappelle ce
qu'a dit notre excellent collègue et ami
le président
Guillaume pour moi il ne peut pas y
avoir de réforme constitutionnelle s'il
n'y a que l'article 1 alors écoutez il y
un qui disent faut supprimer l'article 2
il y autre qui disent et bien s'il n'y a
que l'article 1 ça sert à rien on ne
peut mieux dire que l'article 1 ne sert
à rien c'est ça là je crois que nous en
avons la démonstration et et et le
problème et le problème làdans pour nous
pour nous il n'y a non non c'est pas
sorti du contexte je peux vous tenez
c'est làin bon et on peut reprendre le
Journal Officiel aussi si c'est
nécessaire mais d'ailleurs c'est très
bien moi ça ne me choque pas la question
la question fondamentale est de
savoir non pas si l'état
d'urgence doit être ou non appliqué il y
a des respons abilité gouvernementale et
en contrôle du Parlement la question
pour nous est de savoir s'il doit être
constitutionnalisé et nous nous
considérons majoritairement et c'est
notre droit c'est notre approche que ça
ne sert strictement à rien en dépit de
tout ce que l'on a essayé de nous
expliquer savemment au niveau du droit
alors les symboles c'est extrêmement
intéressant mais faisons du droit la
constitutionnalisation il est évident
que ça n'apporte rien et s'il ne restait
que l'article 1 ben ça ne servirait
encore moins à quelque chose je ne vous
le fais pas dire et mes propos font écho
aux propos du Premier ministre hier qui
a voulu si je dire en provoquant avec
des mots très dur notre haute assemblée
pour indiquer que nous avons fait des
pas et l'article 1 est un exemple où la
constitutionalisation de l'état
d'urgence nous laissait perplexe nous
allons l'adopter c'est aussi une
maintendue que nous faisons vis-à-vis du
propos du président de la République et
des engagements qu'il a pris au Congrès
à Versailles mais peut-être pour un écho
à ce à ce que dit notre notre collègue
maçon et puis hier nous avons beaucoup
évoqué Anna arent et M revenu je je cite
de mémoire un un
passage un
passageétat totalitaire où où elle dit
que que les les méthodes utilisées par
les États totalitaires pour faire face
au problèmes auquel ils ont donc à faire
face survivront à leur
défaite j'ai l'impression que vouloir
régler de tels problèmes par des
méthodes uniquement en augmentant les
contraintes policières les contraintes
diverses enfin et cetera c'est c'est pas
la voie suivie par démocratie même s'il
faut pas avoir d'illusion même si
précisément il faut avoir des instr des
outils d'exception pour faire face aux
périodes excep au défi exceptionnel mais
précisément le problème c'est que si on
les institutionnalise et bien à partir
de ce moment-là c'est le régime
ordinaire donc je crois que le travail
d'équilibre qu'on essae qu'on essae de
faire insuffisant à mon avis mais c'est
déjà mieux ce que nous faisons le texte
qui nous est venu de de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est effectivement faire un
exercice démocratique difficile qui peut
penser on peut penser qu'il manque un
peu de logique mais c'est ça il faut qu'
quand même un jour et je le dis avec
tout le respect que j'ai pour Pier
Colomba qui est un grand
républicain il faut quand même se dire
on ne peut pas
constamment avoir une espèce de remise
en cause de ce qu'est entre guillemets
d' côté la démocratie et de l'autre côté
l'ordre républicain l'ordre républicain
la sécurité républicaine ça a du
sens franchement l'autorité de l'État
c'est le fondement de l'égalité c'est le
fondement de de la sécurité des gens un
état qui n'a pas d'autorité qui n'a pas
de de mesures dans la constitution ou
par la loi que ce soit l'état d'urgence
que ce soit d'autres mesures c'est un
état faible
qui ne peut pas rassurer les citoyens et
alors c'est la porte ouverte à tous les
excès à tous les extrémismes à toutes
les organisations locales à toutes les
milices et à tout ce qu'on veut
franchement je je je je veux dire que
lorsque la représentation nationale
lorsqu'un gouvernement dans la
République de manière républicaine
organise l'état d'urgence organise un
certain nombre de mesures demande à la
police de la République à l'armée de la
République à la gendarmerie de la
République d'assurer l'ordre je préfère
l'ordre républicain au désordre des
extrêmes et au désordres des extrêmes
qui poussera à des communautarismes
alors l'état d'urgence dans la
Constitution moi j'étais pas forcément
pour l'intégrer mais en tout état de
cause que l'état d'urgence existe en
lui-même que les mesures prises y
compris dans la Constitution avec l'état
de siège existe c'est la force d'une
démocratie sous le contrôle du Parlement
de pouvoir l'exercer euh mon groupe dans
sa majorité a demandé la suppression de
cet article nous
reconnaissons les améliorations
apportées à cet article grâce aux
travaux de la commission et de Monsieur
bas que je salue euh nous ne sommes pas
convaincus par l'article 1er euh de la
enfin par c'est la
constitutionnalisation de cet article
1er parce que euh de sur croi nous yons
plutôt des inconvénients surtout une
éventuelle pérénisation de l'état
d'urgence ce qui peut s'avérer à la
longue dangereux sans compter la posture
politique que représente cette
constitutionnalisation il
serait en plus
inopportun de participer à cette posture
surtout que cette
constitutionnalisation risque en l'état
puisque elle elle ne sera pas voté à
l'identique dans les deux chambres
d'être envoyée au calandre grec avant
l'été nous avons acquis la conviction
que dès lors que l'état d'urgence n'est
pas une simple péripétie il est
nécessaire que des garanties soient
inscrites dans la Constitution quant à
l'utilisation de ce
dispositif nous avons travaillé me
semble-t-il de façon particulièrement
efficace notamment hier soir autour de
l'idée
d'inscrire la
proportionnalité sur le thème de l'état
d'urgence dans la Constitution
premièrement deuxièmement de rappeler
les prérogatives de l'autorité
judiciaire gardienne de la liberté
individuelle et aussi de peaufiner de
ciseler même le contrôle du Parlement un
contrôle permanent du Parlement quant à
l'exécution de l'état d'urgence je crois
sincèrement que le travail qui a été
mené au Sénat depuis quelques heures qui
est l'aboutissement d'ailleurs d'un long
travail en amont est un véritable
travail de constituant dont nous pouvons
nous honorer et je pense que il serait
légitime que le maximum de sénateurs et
de sénatrices sur tous les bancs puisse
voter cet article premier je vous
remercie pendant l'état d'urgence la
démocratie continue la preuve les
élections régionales se sont tenues tout
à fait normalement nous n'avons cessé de
légiférer la possibilité est entière
pour le gouvernement d'engager sa
responsabilité devant l'Assemblée
nationale l'Assemblée nationale
peut-être dissoute et le Parlement peut
réviser la Constitution la preuve c'est
ce que nous sommes en train de faire et
nous ne le faisons pas sous la menace
nous le faisons comme participant au
pouvoir constituant souverain et par
conséquent je crois que il faut quand
même être très attentif donner une telle
extension aux situations dans lesquelles
nous n'aurions plus le droit d'exercer
notre pouvoir
souverain et notamment celui de réviser
la Constitution c'est quelque chose qui
est privatif de droits fondamentaux de
la représentation
nationale je comprends que le général de
Gaulle et le pouvoir constituant en 1958
est interdit de réviser la Constitution
quand l'intégrité
du territoire est atteinte mais oui bien
sûr si vous êtes sous le coup d'une
occupation étrangère vous n'allez pas
réviser votre constitution pour créer
une dictature ça va de soi mais dans les
autres cas je crois qu'il faut être
prudent de ne pas hypothéquer ainsi par
avance notre droit souverain de réviser
la
Constitution voici le résultat du
scrutin numéro 180 sur l'article
1er nombre de votants
346 nombre de suffrages exprimés
339 pour l'adoption
30001 contre 38 le Sénat a adopté il y a
quelques années en 2010 quand la
majorité à laquelle j'appartenais
envisageit la déchéance de nationalité
descit d'or frais étit poussé remettre
en cause l'appartenance à notre nation
d'individus ayant pris les armes contre
les dépositaires de l'autorité publique
constituerait une atteinte intolérable
au principe constitutif de la nation une
entorse à la tradition républicaine que
n'avions-nous pas entendu de la part de
ceux qui aujourd'hui professe le
contraire justement au nom de la
République on admet que la nationalité
peut être retirée selon cet article 2
pour un crime ou un délit constituant
une atteinte grave à la vie de la nation
nous pouvions donc dire que nous étions
prophétiques cette fois-ci c'est une
majorité d'orientation différente qui
admet dans la norme fondamentale cette
déchéance de nationalité comment ne pas
s'en réjouir j'approuve cette volonté de
faciliter la tâche du législateur en lui
donnant cet appui le plus solide qu'est
la Constitution au demeurant il s'agit
d'étendre le domaine reconnu au
législateur prévu par l'article 34 de la
Constitution nous précisons juste un
alinéa de cet article à cet égard je
rends hommage à la capacité de notre 5e
République à s'adapter à un contexte de
crise et à la plasticité de sa
constitution tout ce qui permet à notre
pays de se séparer de ceux qui
l'assassinent va dans le bon sens j'ai
toujours été opposé à l'idée de la
déchéance de nationalité et plus encore
pour la déchéance de nationalité des
Français nés français c'est un vieux
combat je l'ai mené quand l'extrême
droite voulait relancer ses thèses je
l'ai mené quand une partie de la droite
a essayé de nous expliquer qu'il fallait
l'inscrire dans la Constitution je le
mène aujourd'hui plus encore
qu'hier plus encore qu'hier
pourquoi parce que s'il est vrai que le
terrorisme est un enjeu
considérable qui doit mobiliser toute la
nation la manière de le le combattre
procède de trois
exigences la première l'efficacité dans
la prévention des actes organiser nos
forces de police notre justice nos
forces de renseignement et chacun le en
convient la déchéance de nationalité n'a
aucune efficacité en la matière le
deuxième la deuxième exigence c'est de
ne rien céder sur les principes et pour
ma part je considère que le cadre qui
fait la Nation c'est-à-dire le cadre de
la nationalité est un principe
fondamental on peut avoir des désaccords
entre nous et il y en a on peut avoir ce
débat en entre nous et nous le
maintiendront mais un moment où tout est
fait pour essayer de mettre des brèches
dans ce qui sont les failles ou les
désaccords qui sont légitimes en
démocratie ce n'est pas le moment de
remettre en cause les principes d'autant
quand ça n'a aucune
efficacité
troisièmement on nous dit que ça va
rassembler les Français en aucune façon
ça ne rassemblera ça ne nous rassemble
pas déjà entre nous et dans l'histoire
ça ne nous a pas rassemblé
mais plus encore avec le principe que
monsieur maluret vient de décrire soit
on fait d'un côté des apatrides et moi
je suis toujours été contre la patridie
c'est la charge de l'histoire la France
des droits de l'homme doit non seulement
la réduire mais la combattre la patridie
mais mais aussi si ce n'est pas cela
c'est qu'il y aura différenciation donc
inégalité par rapport au droit qu'elle
soit de fait écrit par une méthode ou
par une autre il y a dans idée de
déchéance une forme
d'autoexonération il y a deux discours
celui qui affirme que c'estes
terroristes ne sont pas de vrais
Français et l'autre discours qui
soutient qui ne sont pas de vrais
musulmans d'un côté comme de l'autre il
y a et du vrai mais aussi du dénis or
pour combattre le terroriste nous avons
besoin de percer le fonctionnement du
terrorisme dihadiste en brandissant la
déchéance nous enclenchons un engrenage
de solidarité absurde la déchéance est
la plus mauvaise des réponses
symboliques car elle dessine des
frontières juridiques au cord d'eau en
assignant en fonction de l'identité le
camp des bons et celui des suspects les
suspects ceux qui par leur patronyme
leur aspect physique leur foi réelle ou
supposée se retrouvent dans une
injonction paradoxale lorsqu'ils se
thisent ils sont forcément dans la
complicité et quand ils s'expriment ils
signeraient leur duplicité pour ma part
je dénonce depuis des années la
wabisation de l'islam mondial plus
l'Islam traditionnel culturel spirituel
est mise en cause et la déchéance de
nationalité pour les Français de
confession musulmane a été vécu comme
une mise en cause de cette nature plus
les arguments des promoteurs du
fondamentaliste prospère je remercie
jean-Pierre Sueur de CRE éevé ici contre
les propos du sénateur maçon grand
professionnel de l'amalgame pour qui la
les binationaux seraient une 5è colonne
tout ce qui est excessif est vraiment
insignifiant pour combattre le
terrorisme jihadiste nous devons enrayer
l'offensive de l'islam intégriste ce
combat là ne peut se faire sans les
Français de confession musulmane et pour
associer nos compatriotes ni
victimisation ni stigmatisation et
encore moins et encore moins la
suspicion or c'est bien le mode
d'expression le plus répandu le plus
lâche et le plus sour noix il faut juste
les reconnaître comme des égau des
Français à part entière or la déchéance
de nationalité donne une prime à
l'identité sur la citoyenneté à
contrario si collectivement nous
parvenions à promouvoir l'égalité
formelle et l'égalité des chances à
endiguer l'intégrisme dans nos
territoires et sur les réseaux sociaux
sans stigmatiser les Français de
confessions musulmanes nous offrirons
alors un beau visage à la laïcité et
nous aurons avec nous dans le combat
contre le terrorisme la nation réunie je
vous remercie en ce qui me concerne je
voterai sans hésitation la déchéance de
nationalité dans la définition amendée
par notre commission des lois la mesure
est certes symbolique j'en conviens mais
qui commet un crime de terrorisme
s'exclut du cadre national je voterai
toujours sans hésitation l'article 2 en
ce qu'il
concerne l'attribution comme la déchance
de nationalité dans l'autorité de
l'exécutif il serait d'ailleurs
paradoxal de constitutionnaliser une
peine complémentaire ce qui serait le
cas dans la version initiale du texte
alors que les peines principales ne le
sont pas je ne souhaite pas plus
m'engager sur la voix aventureuse et peu
GLOR
de la patrie dans un débat où beaucoup
sinon tout a été dit ceci se comprend au
regard de sa charge émotionnelle où l'on
convoque histoire culture et valeurs je
maintient avec conviction le fait que ce
texte n'est pas un texte de
rassemblement tel qu'il est je maintiens
le fait que sa consti
titutionnalisation sur la déchéance de
nationalité d'ailleurs comme sur l'état
d'urgence n'est pas
utile et que certes on nous a dit
longuement hier et encore aujourd'hui
qu'il s'agissait d'un
symbole moi je suis toujours
inquiet quand on parle plus de symbole
que de règles de
droit ce qui est important c'est d'avoir
une règle de droit adapté aux besoins de
l'évolution de la société certes donc la
loi n'est pas immuable la Constitution
non plus on peut la réviser mais
utiliser un projet de loi de révision
constitutionnelle pour des
objectifs qui me paraissent
malheureusement peu conformes avec
l'idée de rassemblement je crois que ce
n'est pas bien et
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas la voie qui
doit être choisie euh pour rassembler
les Français dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme nous sommes tous ici
convaincu qu'il est nécessaire et que
tout doit être fait pour lutter contre
les terroristes au point de vue matériel
au point de vue humain voir des
modifications législatives et il y en a
eu d'ailleurs lorsque l'état d'urgence
la la loi est venue en discussion ici ça
a été très bien fait maintenant arrêtons
je dirais que l'urgence mes chers
collègues
l'urgence c'est que ce projet de
révision constitutionnelle tombe en
déchéance monsieur le Président je
demande la
priorité sur l'amendement de la
commission dont le numéro est le 14 et
il s'en suivra naturellement que cette
priorité devrait s'étendre logiquement
aux amendements qui suivent cet
amendement 14 nous sommes
à un moment important de de nos de de
nos discussions
et vais
essayer pas de vous convaincre en tout
cas de rappeler un certain nombre
d'arguments qui amène le gouvernement à
donner un avis défavorable à à cette
amendement numéro
14 le débat est nourri riche des
interventions d'une très grande qualité
nous l'avons les uns les autres compris
et c'est vrai c'est c'est vrai
que c'est n pas vrai forcément sur tous
les bancs et c'est tout à fait
respectable mais c'est vrai que c'est
ces attentats terribles nous l'avons
tous dit avec nos
mots ont sans doute amener nos
compatriotes à repenser chacun qu'est-ce
que cela voulait dire être français et à
réfléchir au fond à cette belle idée si
française qu'est la nation c'est vrai
vous préprez vous préférez et c'est le
cœur de la discussion bien sûr une
déchéance de nationalité prononcé
seulement contre certains terroristes en
l'occurrence les binationaux là où le
gouvernement et l'Assemblée visaient
tous les terroristes sans
distinction et donc c'est là où je ne
suis pas le président retillot et je
vous suis pas il faut vous expliquz à
nos concitoyens là aussi cette
exigence à géométrie variable le mot est
peut-être pas bien choisi selon que l'on
est mononational ou pas même si encore
une fois nous parlons de terroristes
ayant commis des actes barbares le
gouvernement et une majorité des 3/5e à
l'Assemblée nationale ont proposé une
solution qui limite considérablement le
risque de créer des apatrides détenteur
en France ça a été rappelé d'ailleurs
dans les débatères d'un statut
protecteur des droits élémentaires le
débat il est là en
1958 la République est menacée par les
guerr colonial la guerre
d'Algérie l'État est menacé la fin de la
deuxè Guerre mondiale n'a que 13 ans le
souvenir de Vichi est là
partout et donc la constitution de 58
en réalité s'appuie sur l'état et la
République parle peu de la nation
l'article 20 le Gouvernement détermine
et conduit la politique de la nation
mais finalement la nation elle n'aarît
qu'assez peu dans la Constitution parce
qu'elle n'est pas en cause parce qu'elle
n'est pas remise en cause et parce que
l'identité nationale et la nation
française en 1958 n'est pas un problème
n'est pas une difficulté n'est pas une
interrogation en 2016 elle l'est elle
est
l'interpellation le terrorisme mais
avant même le terrorisme le doute le
scepticisme sur ce qu'est la nation
française depuis 10 ans c'est vrai c'est
vrai les Français se demandent ce qu'est
la France aujourd'hui les Français que
demandent se demandent ce qui est notre
destin commun alors inscrire les
éléments sur la déchéance et sur ce
qu'est la nation dans la Constitution
oui c'est un geste fort et c'est un
geste fort au-delà du terrorisme parce
que la question de la nation devient une
question essentielle pour ce qui est
notre République et notre pays il n'y a
pas de majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
si l'on évoque la double nationalité et
il n'y a pas de majorité au Sénat si on
la refuse nous sommes donc dans cette
situation de blocage la logique voudrait
dire qu'à partir de là nous nous
arrêtons dans la démarche et nous
passons à autre chose considérant qu'il
y a d'autres enjeux dans le pays à
traiter mais la question qu'on peut se
poser de savoir pourquoi on arrive à ce
blocage on arrive à ce blocage pour une
raison assez simple et que personne
n'évoque ici c'est que la question est
mal posée on définit pas la nation en
regardant vers l'arrière le débat sur
l'identité nationale l'a montré l'a
révélé les blocages les impasses les
ambiguïtés de ce débat ont été il y a
quelques années évidents et ont mis mal
à l'aise toute la nation française le
problème c'est que en organisant le
débat sur la déchéance nous avons voulu
regarder effectivement le débat de cette
façon la nation nous devons la définir
vers l'avant en regardant vers l'avant
en lui construisant un avenir et si nous
voulions mettre en place une mesure
symbolique ce n'est pas en excluant les
terroristes de la communauté nationale
c'est en intégrant dans la communauté
nationale comme l'ont fait nos ancêtres
de la Révolution française avec la
formule des citoyens d'honneur ceux qui
se battent contre daè dans des
conditions épouvantables pourquoi par
exemple ne pas donner alors la
citoyenneté d'honneur à ces femmes
kurdes qui se battent contre daesh
là-bas en Syrie et sur le territoire de
l'Irak ça c l' aurait un sens ça c'est
un symbole ça sexprimerait une France
qui va vers l'avant qui regarde loin
devant elle et pas simplement pour
régler des comptes avec ceux qu'elle a
simplement à sanctionner à punir mais
pas à exclure parce que la République
n'exclut pas elle se définit d'une autre
manière si nous avions et moi j'avais
des doutes quant à la crédibilité de ce
qui a été voté par l'Assemblée nationale
ou dans quant à sa cohérence j'ai
davantage encore de doute sur
l'amendement qui nous est
proposé car cet amendement est très
clair la déchéance ne s'appliquerait
qu'aux B nationaux
point j'ai dit tout à
l'heure que bien entendu il s'agit de
criminel et il s'agit de personnes qui
s'excluent d'une certaine manière
elle-même de toute nationalité
d'ailleurs
mais nous
savons et moi j'ai toujours cela présent
à
l'esprit que le texte tel qu'il a été é
présenté a pour effet collatéral que les
5 millions de binationaux qui sont en
France perçoivent cela comme une
inégalité vous avez dit ce
qui la nation mais c'est ni à vous ni à
moi d'ailleurs de le dire la
Constitution définit ce qu'est la France
la France je parle pas de telle ou telle
institution non la Constitution dans son
premier article dit la France est une
République indivisible laïque
démocratique et sociale elle assure
l'égalité devant la loi de tous les
citoyens sans distinction d'origine de
race ou de religion je répète elle dit
la France est une république elle
définit la France comme une république
et elle ne définit pas la France à
partir de de l'appréciation qu'à chacun
de ce qu'est l'identité parce que ça ça
nous divise bon je vais pas faire de
grand discours vous savez que de toute
façon nous sommes opposés à la déchéance
de de nationalité et que bien évidemment
nous ne pouvons accepter cet amendement
14 qui rétablit la déchéance des
binationaux pourquoi parce que je l'ai
déjà dit aussi et nous l'avons dit cela
est porteur d'une
stigmatisation de l'ensemble de ceux qui
portent au moins deux nationalités
puisquon peut en avoir plus que plus que
deux et qui m même si ils n'ont
strictement rien à voir avec le débat
sur le terrorisme se sentent pointés du
doigt comme finalement n'étant pas tout
à fait Français comme les autres donc
refus absolu de de voter en faveur de
cet amendement unanimement le groupe
Caliste républicain votera contre
l'amendement numéro 14 et votera contre
l'article l'article 2 pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord je crois que ce qui
vient de se passer tout au long de de
ces deux jour a été un débat intéressant
parfois vif et les uns et les autres ont
pu exprimer leur leur leur position ça
n'a échappé à personne que dans notre
groupe le groupe socialiste nous n'avons
pas la la même position les uns et les
autres c'est bien normal sur un sujet
comme celui-ci la clause de conscience
doit jouer chacun doit doit l'exprimer
une trentaine de nos collègues ont même
présenté un amendement pour supprimer le
pour supprimer l'article 2 parce qu'ils
sont contre la déchéance de nationalité
que ce soit dans la version Assemblée
nationale soit dans la version nouvelle
version qui va être votée présentée par
le président de de de de la commission
une un plus grand nombre souhaite
arriver à un accord dans un au Congrès
et que l'on arrive à trouver une
solution et cette solution elle doit
passer le premier ministre l'a très bien
dit tout à l'heure par une avancée des
deux chambres à la fois l'Assemblée
nationale et à la fois le le le le Sénat
tout le monde l'a dit depuis 2 jours
quel que soi les positions que nous
parlons de terrorisme que la France a
été touchée qu'il faut des réponses et
que que le discours du du président de
la République congrès de versaill il pas
été jugé sur telle ou telle phrase il a
été jugé sur sur son sur son ensemble un
point d'accord avec le Premier ministre
sur le départ sur ce qui explique notre
présence ici d'abord le
terrorisme le point de départ c'est
aussi la déclaration du Président de la
République et sa proposition de modifier
la Constitution nous n'avions rien
demandé comme l' rappelé tout à l'heure
françoisetto c'est le point de
départ 2è observation nous avons jugé
que pour autant cette idée de la
déchéance pouvait être utile parce que
elle nous renvoie ce que nous sommes et
nous pensons que si la lutte est longue
notre capacité à mener le combat c'est
aussi notre capacité à reprendre
possession des raisons qui font que nous
sommes ensemble qui font que nous sommes
un peuple parce que dans une dém oce on
lutte avec les armes on lutte avec des
arsenaux juridiques mais on lutte
d'abord avec les volontés pas seulement
individuel parce que la France vous le
savez ça n'est pas une jueos d'individu
la France ça n'est pas non plus un
archipel de communauté ou un archipel de
tribu donc ce débat est important il est
important à un moment où trop souvent on
a encouragé ici ou là la
dépolitisation la vie des peuples la
réduction de la vie des peuples aux
conditions de leur existence matérielle
en oubliant de leur parler de ce qu'ils
sont et nous sommes une nation civique
c'est la France qui a inventé cette
forme particulière d'être je
maintiens avec conviction le fait que ce
texte n'est pas un texte de
rassemblement tel qu'il est je maintiens
le fait que sa cons la constitutionnal
sur la déchéance de nationalité
d'ailleurs comme sur l'état d'urgence
n'est pas
utile et que certes on nous a dit
longuement hier et encore aujourd'hui
qu'il s'agissait d'un
symbole moi je suis toujours
inquiet quand on parle plus de symboles
que de règles de
droit ce qui est important c'est d'avoir
une règle de droit adaptée au besoins de
l'évolution de la société certes donc la
loi n'est pas immuable la Constitution
non plus on peut la réviser mais
utiliser un projet de loi de révision
constitutionnelle pour des
objectifs qui me paraissent
malheureusement peu conforme avec l'idée
de rassemblement je crois que ce n'est
pas bien et
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas la voie qui
doit être choisie pour pour rassembler
les Français dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme nous sommes tous ici
convaincus qu'il est nécessaire et que
tout doit être fait pour lutter contre
les terroristes au point de vue matériel
au point de vue humain voir des
modifications législatives et il y en a
eu d'ailleurs lorsque l'état d'urgence
la loi est venue en discussion ici ça a
été très bien fait maintenant arrêtons
je dirais que l'urgence mes chers
collèguesur
c'est que ce projet de révision
constitutionnelle tombe en
déchéance bien chers collègues voici le
résultat du scrutin numéro 183 sur
l'article 2 nombre de votants 344 nombre
de suffrages exprimés
336 pour l'adoption
186 contre 150 le Sénat a adopté
l'article
2 il s'agit ici d'insérer après
l'article 2 un article permettant
désormais au président de nationalité
étrangèr de pouvoir voter en France lors
des élections locales il a souvent été
question de symbole ici dans notre
hémicycle en voilà un accorder le droit
de vote à des milliers d'hommes et de
femmes vivantes en France travaillant en
France et payant leurs impôts en France
au-delà de ce symbole il s'agit avant
tout d'un signal fort la République
intègre rassemble et assure l'égalité en
son sein le droit de vote des id
étranger est un formidable outil
d'intégration non seulement pour les
étrangers eux-mêmes mais aussi pour
leurs familles pour leurs enfants pour
leurs proches car comment montrer
l'exemple et encourager au vote quand on
est soi-même privé de ce droit il serait
également un formidable rempart contre
le communitarisme en associant tous les
citoyens d'où qu'ils viennent au choix
collectif et aux décisions qui les
engagent mais aussi en marquant
l'appartenance à une même communauté de
destin unanimement le groupe socialiste
républicain votera contre cette C ou
cette cet amendement sur l'explication
qui ont été donnés par le président de
la commission et par le le le ministre
certains d'entre nous peuvent penser que
le droit de vote pour les pour les
étrangers est est quelque chose
d'important bon
certains oui bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
sauf que là je pense vraiment que tout à
l'heure les les mots d'apaisement du
Premier ministre du président du
président rotaillot si nous voulons
arriver à une réforme constitutionnelle
et si nous voulons faire en sorte de pas
trop mettre d'arrête je pense que ce
cette cette amendement que l'on soit
pour que l'on soit contre mais mis dans
ce texte constitutionnel ne ne collerait
pas c'est pas le bon véhicule et je
crois que c'est pas le moment c'est la
c'est la raison pour laquelle la quasi
unanimité de notre groupe votera contre
donc je mets au voix ces deux
amendements avec deux avis défavorables
qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient ils
ne sont pas adoptés voilà vous avez pu
suivre une partie des débats autour de
la révision constitutionnelle vous le
savez les sénateurs ont limité la
déchéance de nationalité au sol
binationaux ce qui a conduit François
Hollande à enterrer cette révision
constitutionnelle vous pouvez revoir
bien sûr ce programme sur notre site
internet
publicsenat.fr
I